somebody hands you a data set like this
and this could be this could be
literally anything this could be the
value of a stock that's changing over
time this could be the position of a
robot you can use your imagination
taking or whatever you do and work for
yourself it doesn't matter now
you're given this and you are asked to
predict what this value is going to be
at some future time that's not shown on
the graph so you look at this thing
and you say okay in the beginning it's
pretty much just chaos I don't know what
I would do there but maybe as it goes
it's it's getting a little periodic and
maybe I can exploit that somehow you
might be able to make some headway with
this but the punchline is it's not it's
not going to be trivial to do this so
now what if instead you you happen to
know that you could take this time
series and decompose it into these eight
component parts if you if you look
closely at each of these it's basically
a sinusoid that's that has some decaying
exponential envelope to it and
predicting what any one of these is
going to do at some future time seems
like a much simpler task so the question
that should be coming up in your head at
this point is where on earth did I get
these component functions from and how
do you figure out what the what the
weighting is or the recipe to get back
the original data so these are the types
of problems that got me really
interested in this field it turns out
that you can do this with linear algebra
despite the fact that nothing on here
looks like a straight line but we're
gonna we're gonna look at some fun stuff
like this and hopefully you'll leave
with some inspiration to go and keep
digging up more of this material for
yourself before I further the ideas that
I'm gonna share with you today I learned
through these really excellent courses
taught by Professor Steven Boyd and
Sanjay Lal at Stanford University these
guys have created a tremendous resource
in that they put their their course
lectures and notes online for free as
well as books on the material
yeah please capture these links I'll
show them again on my final slide and I
can you know post them online if there's
any sort of resources for the follow up
but everybody here please check this out
if you're interested it's it's a
tremendous resource so Who am I and how
did I get so excited about this why why
do I care why did I put all this energy
into making a talk on this so I am one
of the first engineers at a company
called spry health at spry we have made
the first fda-cleared wearable wristband
that monitors vital signs continuously
for people who are living with chronic
illnesses so my job as part of the
algorithms team is to take the raw
physiological information that we get
from our sensors and use that to
estimate what are the vital signs of the
wearer
at that particular moment in time and
then on top of this we our aim is to
build up this enormous and unprecedented
data set of vital signs through days and
months and then use that information to
predict whether or not somebody is at
the risk of returning to the hospital or
the emergency room in the work that I do
it's essentially impossible for me to
pick up a research paper and get through
it without needing to understand at some
level the properties of vectors and
matrices but more interestingly to me
than that is that if you whatever
discipline you work in if you have a
problem and you can cram and Bend and
stretch this thing to look like this
then the only thing you need to
are the properties of this matrix a and
the rest will sort itself out you can
take ideas from finance and use them to
solve whatever you're doing and maybe
fluid mechanics problems like this come
up literally everywhere and we could
spend you know days just going through
examples but I figured let's just start
with a few to to get warmed up so if we
are in classical mechanics we could have
a rocket or some object the vector X
could be a list of a few forces acting
at different points on the object the
vector Y can be a list of the the total
resulting forces or torques and the
matrix a then contains all of the
information about the geometry that's
specific to that that object we can
switch gears entirely and go into
something for business operations so you
can have your vector X now representing
the the price of all of the component
parts that you use Y can be the prices
of all of your finished products or you
know how much you need to charge for
those and a then the rows of a are the
sorts of recipes for each of your
products and this becomes a kind of Bill
of Materials switching let's see we
could work
keyboard we can switch fields again this
time to statistics and this one's a
little more subtle
so here what becomes your X vector from
an autoregressive model is actually the
coefficients for each time lag you'll
notice the A's are now the vector on the
right y is the output of the model
itself so this is now your time series
of data and your matrix a is this kind
of weird concept where each row is a
stacked time window out of your data
what I really like about this example in
addition to the the one I should at the
beginning is it emphasizes that we don't
just have to talk about straight lines
when we were doing linear algebra if
you've worked with AR models before you
know these things can can have all kinds
of crazy shapes and behavior so so we're
not we're not stuck with lines and we
can generalize this further I have made
absolutely no requirements about how you
get the numbers that are in your matrix
a these can come from absolutely hideous
functions depending on what field you're
in they can be you know Bessel functions
of the fiftieth order it doesn't matter
as if it's the elements that are in your
matrix as long as the weights that tell
you how to mix those functions are first
order then you can still work with this
framework so before diving in to some of
the specific topics I want to cover a
little bit of a disclaimer this field is
so deep and has so much richness that
there's no possible way to get through
it in a 30 minute talk so the way that
I'm going to cover as much as I can is
by being completely irresponsible with
my math I'm not gonna prove anything I'm
gonna wave my arms a lot just trust me
on it everything that you see here is
that you can google search and find
proofs of it very quickly this is all
well documented and on top of that I put
together a series of Python notebooks
I'll post a link to on my final slide
which goes into more examples that I
wanted to fit in but didn't have time
you can play with you know the source
code how to generate some of the figures
that I'm gonna show so just know that
that's coming up okay so with that
preamble out of the way let's you know
start dusting off some of our neurons
from our you know classes that we took a
long time ago
the first topic that I want to start
with is matrix rank so as a refresher
the rank of a matrix is a property it's
an integer and that number tells you
what is the largest grouping of rows or
columns that you can take and have it
form a linearly independent set it's
easiest to explain that an example so
with this matrix that I've shown here
I'm gonna use numpy arrays for
everything no matter how much I want to
and how hard I try I will not be able to
take these first two rows and scale them
and add them together in some way that
produces this third row so these three
vectors form a linearly independent set
and the rank of this matrix numpy
cheerfully tells us is three now the the
rank has to be less than the number of
rows or columns are equal to that so as
soon as we add another row to this
matrix it's this set will no longer be
linearly independent in this case you
can see I can take two times the first
row plus the second row plus the third
row I get the fourth row
so the rank stays the same at three and
we would say this is not a full rank
matrix because of that and you know
flipping rows and columns it doesn't
matter so as soon as we introduce some
idea that there's redundant information
in this matrix immediately what can come
to your mind is there's an opportunity
for compression I'll demonstrate how
this is going to work with a pretty
contrived example but say that you have
a matrix that you want to put on a
computer
and this thing has a million rows but
only two columns and the second column
is exactly double the first column now
it would be it would be silly to store
all of this in memory when you can
automatically save half of the space by
just storing the first column and
remembering if you ever need to index
into the second column just multiply by
two so I've shown here how we can
express that idea in sort of a matrix
equation notation you can take a and you
can factor it into these two two things
and it's a you know a pretty small
matrix but it's matrix this idea of
course generalizes and it turns out any
matrix if you know the rank can be split
into two smaller matrices whose shape is
determined by the rank and our
mathematician friends have given us a
whole host of tools that will give you
different types of these matrices so
this is absolutely possible now if you
go through pretty simple arithmetic to
calculate how many numbers do you have
to store you find out you need m times
and numbers for the original matrix but
if your rank R is much smaller than
either of those dimensions you can have
a very considerable savings in how much
you you need to store and somewhat
amusingly if you ask the question how
many floating-point operations or
multiplications does it take to multiply
some vector X by this matrix the math is
exactly the same you you have M times n
flops for for the full matrix and if
your rank is low you can save quite a
bit of you know time and efficiency by
using the the factored form
okay starting to feel a little bit warm
juices are going the next subject is
another one that I think everybody would
have seen in kind of an introductory
linear algebra course this is gonna be I
can vectors and eigen values who here
remember is going through lots of
loose-leaf paper writing out a
polynomial and finding the zeros I here
chuckles in hand so okay I'm not alone
on this I can't count how many trees I
must have gone through I certainly never
had any idea why I was doing all this it
turns out to be very useful okay I'll
use a picture just to remind us all what
these things are suppose you start with
a vector X in some space and you
multiply that with a square matrix this
has the effect of transforming it and in
general if you start with this X here
you'll end up with a new vector that
probably points in some other direction
in space for any matrix there are a few
special directions that if you transform
those vectors you end up with an output
that is a scaled version of the vector
you started with written as an equation
we have a V equals lambda V where lambda
is the scaling factor and these things
turn out to come up so often we give
them a fancy name we use eigen which
means same and so you have V as the
eigenvector and lambda as the eigenvalue
there are quite a few situations where
these become useful but the one that
kind of grabbed my attention the most
when I was learning this it comes up in
systems that evolve over time so within
this context X our vector is going to
represent a list of properties that
define a system at some moment in time
these could be parameters in a
statistical model or in physics a good
one is it could be the position velocity
and acceleration of some object
the matrix a is contains all the
information about how you update the
state of your system from one time to
the next time step it's it's possible to
write out an expression for the state at
any time given the state at the
beginning time and the relationship has
entirely made of terms that have this
structure with one of the eigenvectors
and a coefficient that is an eigenvalue
raised to a power that grows with time
the ellipses in this are hiding some
really ugly terms but those also you
know end up having the structure there's
factorials and binomial coefficients and
things and I just wanted to highlight
this here so I find this completely
amazing
you know we introduced eigenvalues and
eigenvectors as these kind of you know
funny geometric concepts and here they
show up in a system or in when we're
talking about how things evolve it
didn't have to be that way and beyond
that because of the particular structure
here there turn out to be only a few
simple things that can happen so we can
have Augen values with a magnitude of 1
in which case those terms in your
expression don't do anything as time
advances this you can think of this as a
kind of steady state behavior you can
have I Gonville use whose magnitude is
less than 1 and as time passes those
terms dampen out and go to 0 and if
you're in you know some sort of
mechanical system this tends to
represent the kind of stability things
get calmer over time and then of course
the third is if your eigen value has a
magnitude greater than 1 as more time
passes the weight of those terms is
going to explode to infinity and this
you would think of as kind of an
unstable system one detail even if all
of the entries in your matrix a are real
you can still have come
flex eigenvalues and eigenvectors and
the way that manifests is that you have
a periodic oscillation but the
asymptotic behavior is exactly the same
so a fun way to play with this idea and
to see it in practice comes up with
Markov chains I have people here worked
with Markov chains before just to get a
sense I see a couple of hands so for for
people who haven't seen this before it's
a I think a pretty straightforward idea
imagine that you have at any point in
time you can be in one of a few discrete
states and then there's some probability
on every time step given what state
you're in now that you switch to a
different one of the states and that's
about it if you pick one at random and
then you do coin flips and you you know
just write out which state you pass
through over time you'll get it you know
it's a sequence like this and we would
call that a Markov chain and this whole
thing is a Markov process so I picked
you know a situation that might come up
you have an employee who can either be
working thinking or not doing anything
and a classic question that would come
up with a model like this is what is the
probability or what percent of the time
is my employee doing what I want him to
do Markov chains are nice because they
are a completely linear process here are
our state vector is a list of the
probabilities at a particular time that
you are in each of the states and the
transition matrix has a nice
interpretation each entry is the
probability that you in one time step
that you switch from the j 'the state
into the ice state
okay when I was in high school I had a
particularly boring hamster who had a
very set routine it would sleep it would
wake up and run on its wheel and then it
would eat and then we go back to sleep
and it would repeat this ad nauseam so
it's a simple task to write out the
Markov process for my hamster looks
something like this and what I've done
here is I've just written out this is
the the transition matrix that you would
have for a process like this so a
question to you guys what types of
behavior would you expect to see in a
state vector for this process you just
shout things out exactly so one one big
one is that every three time steps you
would expect to come back to where you
started and there's actually one more
that's a little more subtle and if
anybody you can see it so can you say to
be louder so so yes with the so just
reminding that the interpretation of the
vector is that it's probability so you
can have if if you start that all three
states with an equal probability of
occupation then it turns out that will
remain constant as you apply the update
matrix so if we go to numpy and we ask
it to give back the eigenvalues and
eigenvectors of this matrix we can see
two things right away so here we have an
eigenvalue of one which that's going to
represent this kind of unchanging
behavior and this value is associated
with an eigenvector that has equal
entries in all three states so this is
that that second behavior I mentioned
the other two eigenvalues have
complex values and these are a complex
conjugate pair so both of these vectors
turn out to be in this periodic rotation
through the states in the same direction
so I threw together just another type of
transition process and here
we get back that we have all real
eigenvalues one of them is equal to 1
the other two are less than 1 so just
looking at this can you can you make a
guess as to what this system is going to
do over time yeah so that is we're gonna
see any any part of the initial state
that's associated with these two vectors
or that's constructed from these two
vectors is going to go away what's going
to be left is a vector that has all of
its weight in one of the states so we
should see a kind of convergence and if
we if we run the simulation forward
that's exactly what we see all of the
weight that starts in components 2 and 3
goes to 0 component 1 maxes out so
Markov chains as the example that I
chose because they deal with
probabilities turn out to have a
property they will always have an eigen
value exactly equal to 1 and this idea
is one of the fundamental principles of
Google's PageRank algorithm so whether
you like it or not you're actually
interacting with this every single day
which i think is cool for the for the
final topic that I wanted to cover today
I wanted to go with something that isn't
typically seen in a basic linear algebra
class so it'll be new but this I think
is one of the most powerful ideas in the
field it enables you to prove all kinds
of things very very easily and it has
way more applications than there's time
for today so it's called the singular
value decomposition and I'll I'll
introduce it with a bit of a story
fun fact if you take the vectors that
comprise a sphere and you transform them
now with any matrix a it doesn't matter
the shape the resulting output that you
get is an ellipse and as an ellipse you
can define it by a set of principal axes
that are mutually perpendicular or
orthogonal to each other now what's
amazing is if you take these principal
axes and you ask the question what were
the input vectors that mapped onto them
though is also turn out to give you a
set of mutually orthogonal vectors and
it turns out that they actually create a
basis for the input and output space as
a reminder you can think of a basis as
if you were to take your Cartesian axes
and kind of rotate them so we have some
flexibility in how we scale things so to
make it nice and clean we define these
vectors V and U for the the two bases so
that they all have a length of one and
then we'll introduce these scaling
coefficients Sigma so that the math
works out that when you transform one of
the inputs you get the output so these
Sigma's are going to end up being called
singular values which is where the name
comes from now we can do is we can start
with this equation for one of the
vectors and we can actually group all
the vectors together stacking them
horizontally into a matrix and that
gives us a structure that looks like
this one so we have a V equals u big
Sigma now big Sigma is a diagonal matrix
it's almost all zeros except this main
diagonal we put those scaling
coefficients on and the one last step is
we'll just invoke this fact that all of
those input and output vectors are a
mutually orthogonal so these vectors V
and u are what are called orthogonal
matrices
which means that if you multiply them by
the transpose they essentially cancel
out so that lets us rearrange this in
one step and we've just shown that any
single matrix a can be written with the
special form where you have an
orthogonal matrix a diagonal matrix and
an orthogonal matrix this is called the
singular value decomposition and like I
said it shows up a lot so one of one of
the ways in particular is I mentioned
there were you know lots of algorithms
that could give you this low rank
factorization for compression this turns
out to be an easy one you just group
these two and now you've got your two
matrices okay so of the applications for
this thing the one that for me I thought
was the most motivating or most exciting
when I saw it is this idea of the pseudo
inverse the other reason is I think this
is extremely powerful and but when we do
interviews with candidates that spry
it's something that very few people seem
to have come across before so hopefully
this is something I can share with all
of you and it will have a great impact
in the problems that you solve ok say
for this for this set up I'll use an
example from like Mechanical Engineering
we have some kind of heat conductive
plate and we put some thermal limiters
on it this could be you know computer
processor is that as you run them more
they dissipate power into the board and
then we have a couple of sensors that
are placed on the board to measure what
the temperature is and you know the
classic question you would have here is
given the measurement of the temperature
how much power are we dissipating from
our processors the kind of common rule
of thumb wisdom is I need to have as
many equations as I have unknowns in a
problem like this that would translate
mathematically to having a be a square
matrix and then to solve for the unknown
we would need to have a be invertible
and then we could switch the sides and
we get out an estimate of what our what
our own unknown vector X is this is okay
but it has some problems for instance
say my budget gets bigger and now I can
put a fourth sensor on there this like
intuitively this should only give me
more information about my problem but it
kind of breaks our math because we don't
know how to invert a matrix when it's
not square and that fourth sensor makes
our Y vector longer which means you have
an extra row and a and now it's not
square the other possibility is maybe
one of our sensors breaks or maybe
they're expensive and we we can't afford
to put enough of them on there and it
would be much nicer to have a best-guess
or to say something rather than just
throwing up our hands and saying you
know this can't be done so the the
singular value decomposition gives us a
very very quick way to get an answer so
we just we invoke the decomposition and
then if you look at this thing for a
moment you might see that if we multiply
by this thing which it you know it just
ends up being a matrix you can go
through some very simple algebra and all
of this stuff just cancels out I think
let's say I forgot a transpose on there
so this this new matrix is so
significant that it gets a really fancy
name it's called the more penrose
pseudoinverse and there is just a single
line numpy command that will give this
to you and it has some very beautiful
interpretations so if your a matrix is
tall then the pseudoinverse gives you
the least squares solution it minimizes
the sum of squares error and if you
haven't worked with least squares before
this is this picture of finding a best
fit line where you don't necessarily hit
all of your data points but you you end
up being close to them in the other case
if you have a wide matrix then the
pseudo-inverse you at you have multiple
solutions in this case that are exact
but the pseudo-inverse will give you the
one with the smallest sum of squares of
the entries of the vector X and so in a
polynomial regression case this would be
finding the curve that goes through all
your data points but you know has the
least wild swings in it or so to the
lowest order okay
so we'll apply this idea to a real
problem and this is this is how my class
at Stanford opened and blew my mind so
for this imagine that we have something
like a magnetic hard disk that has a
head that can move in a 2-dimensional
plane and we can steer it by you know
tuning to inputs these could be voltages
or currents or something so what we'd
like to do is be able to move from any
starting position to a new target and
we'd like to arrive there smoothly and
you know sort of in a time that we can
control so systems like this and very
commonly mechanical systems turn out to
be well modeled with what are called
linear dynamic systems so this is just
this is a couple of matrices and vectors
X here is again it's a it's some sort of
internal state it's not something we
necessarily measure directly but we
might be able to you know starting from
our original equations know what those
things are
U is whatever the inputs we put in that
we can control and then Y is what we
physically observe so it's kind of the
naive first approach for a problem like
this is let's figure out you know the
solution where X isn't changing over
time and Y is the Y that we want and you
can get this by just you know doing some
arithmetic to to rearrange this and it
turns out that I built a really terrible
harddrive because when I just go
directly to the point
I'm trying to reach my arm completely
overshoots and it swings back and forth
and it vibrates for a while and it takes
a whole bunch of time for this to kind
of dampen out but eventually it does
reach the target that is set for it
okay now let's let's do the fancy
singular value approach that we just
learned so if we if we take the linear
dynamic dynamic system and unroll it as
a recursion we get kind of a scary
looking thing that gives us our final
position at any time as a function of
all of the inputs leading up to that
time and okay now this this looks gross
but if you you know take a breath step
back you know relax for a second you
realize this is just y equals mu this is
a simple matrix equation and that means
we can use a pseudo inverse and find the
U with the smallest sum of squares that
gets us to Y at the time that we want so
if we run this simulation the the inputs
that we get out are these completely
bizarre things and I challenge you to
come up with those on your own but if
you look at what the position of our our
mechanical arm does it kind of you know
wobbles around for a bit and then at the
time 800 seconds that I chose for this
it locks in exactly where I wanted it to
go and it stays there for all future
times no overshoot and it turns out I
can make this arrival time arbitrarily
small and if this will still work
there's a trade-off that you might need
to use bigger input voltages to get
there but you can do it you know
whenever you want okay so right on cue
I'd like to you know just review several
topics that we've covered so we
introduced with all these examples of
where linear algebra algebra comes up
and we said you know we're dealing with
situations that can look much more
complicated than straight lines we
talked about the rank of a matrix and
how you can exploit that for compression
efficiency we went into eigenvalues and
eigenvectors and
we looked at Markov chains and how you
can make statements and predictions
about how systems will evolve over time
and then we introduced this new idea of
the singular value decomposition and we
showed a fun example with the hard disk
there so that's that's the end of my
talk I'd like to leave this slide up
just so that people can have access to
this spry is always hiring and we're
looking for people like you so please
reach out to me if you're curious and
want to learn more I'll be around for
the full conference I mentioned I had a
notebook with more of these examples
that link is right here these are the
Stanford resources and then some some
extra topics if you you know this stuff
and you want to you know go deeper into
something new so with that thank you
very much for your time and attention